[Music]
okay everybody i am so so thrilled today
because i am joined by mamadou aceh aka
dan in archive 81 which is out on
netflix now so there's spoilers in this
interview so make sure you watch season
one first and then come back mama do how
you doing today
great steve how are you doing
i'm doing great man so um i love this
show by the way you're amazing in it the
show is so good
um was there any hesitation for you
though at first taking apart like this
or did you know you wanted to do it like
right out of the gates
um oh the part the part is amazing um i
i knew the part was something that i
wanted to to engage with
immediately when i read it um
i i was just finishing wrapping jurassic
and
and you know it was the middle of covid
and that was the only hesitation but uh
i was very impressed with how netflix
handled the whole code situation i felt
very protected so you know my my fears
were late but that was the only real
hesitation that i had
yeah no that that's good to hear too
that netflix on top of that and that's
exciting about jurassic yeah for sure um
but also with the prep for this
character of dan knowing this is based
off a podcast did you listen to the
podcast first did you kind of keep that
separate no i listened to a couple
episodes and i spoke with rebecca
and she suggested maybe not because
we're going to go in a different
direction and i also you know we both
agreed that you know just getting all
these voices that i was going to be
engaging with and embodying probably
wasn't a great idea so uh you know we
kind of took the
took that out of the equation but it's a
great podcast the few episodes of the
last two hours actually i wanted to
listen to more
um so i highly recommend people check it
out it's cool
yeah and what i love about the show does
a good balance of like respecting some
stuff in the podcast making its own
which is really good like that and
yeah and what's interesting too is every
time i watch a character like this with
dan like he's so isolated like how far
do you let yourself go into that does it
get dark for you when you're doing this
character absolutely
so
i
i mean first i mean
we shared
very similar circumstances i mean i i
didn't have any kind of uh life
i was shooting the show to be honest i
would go to set
come home
learn lines maybe veg out a little bit
wake up go to set like that was that was
what i did for about six months
no hyperbole
um so yeah there was a intense
loneliness that uh i never felt
um particularly being in the dead of
winter in pittsburgh um yeah i i was i
was definitely
i was definitely feeling the dark yeah
yeah
so
now i don't get to ask many people this
but
how was it having a rat as a scene
partner was that uh interesting process
was it difficult
yes
yes it was
as far as rats go
that is as good as it gets though
princess her name's princess okay
princess the rat
god love her as far as the rat goes but
man not
not something that i i
i was super keen on
to be frank
got you no well you guys have great
chemistry it's so crazy
um also what i love too about your
performance is this is a master class in
face acting and facial expressions by
you and reacting
um
are you though seeing the footage on the
screen are you kind of looking at a
screen a green screen mostly with a lot
of the moments with dan looking at the
monitors um a little of both there are
some
some scenes that were fortunately
recorded that i could actually watch and
they put up on the monitor for me
um
and then there are obvious some scenes
like with well not only get into spoiler
territory but they're in some scenes
that just weren't shot yet that i had to
uh imagine
um
so that was uh
that but i mean that was kind of fun for
me actually um because you could just
your imagination is is boundless so you
can do whatever you wanted with it um
you could
you know just fully embody it in the way
that you needed to like
you know you have you have an end goal
for what the scene requires and you just
figure it out from there and it's like
okay what will get me to this point if i
just have to imagine it you can do
whatever you want so it was kind of
freeing in a sense
um yeah i i enjoyed it but
it's always nice to see you know what's
going on
and there's this young actor in the show
ariana neal i remember the first episode
i had to like observe watch some of her
scenes
and um and having her and she's so
wonderfully moving and simple and so so
great as a young just such a young actor
um i just have to i just i always think
about her
in this particular scene because it
really just moved me
yeah
did you meet the certain characters
though before you shot those scenes like
the scenes you have with melody where
you're in the dream sequences did you
shoot those first and then you got to
see them later on the footage or was it
your first experience with their acting
on this footage you're watching
um
yeah i know a lot of the scenes
but actually
they're well
it wasn't so much like we had because a
lot of the show i'm kind of
by myself
but um
there were there i remember the first
one of the first scenes i shot i was
following melody
through a corridor um but we didn't have
any like direct interaction and then the
next thing i remember shooting was um
watching her
in in video form and but then you know i
i also knew her for a long time prior um
yeah so yeah anyway
yo no and it's great because in any form
like it's just amazing what you pull off
doing these scenes isolated but also
doing scenes with other actors it's
really impressive stuff so what also is
impressive with this story is that
you know we see this character arc with
dan if someone's kind of losing it a
little more and more as the season goes
on how
as an actor do you plan that out like to
time it out just right you know what i
mean where you feel like you're not
jumping the gun too fast or stuff like
that
well the circumstances are clear um
and i don't have to really worry about
that if i just like there's the script
is the blueprint and if you you know
embody like if you have the
circumstances and you're living through
those circumstances
that kind of takes care of that issue
for you so you don't have to you i'm not
i wasn't worried about jumping again i
was just worried about reacting to the
truth of the situation as it presented
himself especially as he gets more and
more confirmation that he's not crazy
so
you know it's like look this isn't just
me this is there's something going on
here um so that
that can also look like someone's losing
their mind
oh for sure and but you're right too
that it becomes that he's not really
going crazy in it he is of sense here so
my question for you though if mamadou
was in this same situation as dan when
you were even reading the story is there
any moment where you there was something
you would have done differently than dan
like something that stood out to you
yeah
zero chance of taking a job from someone
like that before
[Laughter]
like i don't like this guy
i'm good
i have a great life going on
and i love that show's over
okay so also too i want to bring out one
of my favorite scenes is when dan is
hitting the wall with a wrench
um and it's clearly alluding to the
shining and we have references to the
shiny even said by mark with the axe and
uh jack torrance um
my question is was there any
performances in film or uh tv that you
watch before this maybe to help with
prep for how you're gonna approach dan
or did you kind of
make it just from imagination oh you
know what's crazy the shining didn't
even occur to me
interesting that's interesting i was
like this is the wrench there's the wall
oh my god i love that was that for me um
no i
i certainly don't recall
um
no i uh yeah i can't i can't think of
anything that i watched as reference i i
felt pretty um i felt like i i had a
pretty good handle on
who dan was um
and i i wanted to fully explore what my
my feelings were
with this guy and and just you know
using the script as a blueprint keeping
it at that
yeah no that makes complete sense and um
you would mention too that you knew dina
before this you guys have great
chemistry together um
but what that also brings is people you
know a debate people are gonna have is
do you think dan
loves melody at all meaning like loves
love do you see that or
do you see it maybe more as a friendly
kind of thing
what what
excited me as an actor was seeing
somebody i mean it can go
in whichever way it wants to go
like you know that's not it's really not
my job um but for me what excited me was
seeing somebody
who loved someone
for the sake of loving them not like in
like the romantic sense or anything just
like a kindred spirit like i know you i
know you there's there's a there's a
there's they share something together
that no one else
really can
and i thought it was i thought there was
something wonderful and beautifully
simple about just something that that
simple of a love like i want to help
somebody i want to help you because
i don't know why it's not like i you
know i'm i'm attracted to you or
anything it's like i just
there's something about you that i'm
really
invested in i want to help um that for
me was the motor with dan and for dan's
relationship with melody
i love that
that yeah that that's definitely how i
saw it too and uh
yeah i like to that's like more of like
a fresh take on something like that too
i like that uh
now
at towards the end we see a scene where
dan
is in this other world and he's at the
dinner table with his family
um
i have to ask did a did a part of dan
want to stay at that dinner table in
that moment with his family or
was it something he didn't even think
twice for that
he you know i mean
that's all i wanted to do uh
yeah that's
that's what he's been
i mean for me
the reason he chose this job as an
archivist was to restore what's been
lost
um
and
for other people because he cannot get
what he's lost
that's why i've always thought of him as
like the ultimate romantic but um
it's
he knows it's never going to happen for
him but he has an opportunity to at
least feel it he sees his father he sees
his sister his mother
um and he lost when he was very very
young uh yeah it it
it kills him
to have to leave that table um
man yeah
love i love i love that scene forget it
yes
one of the best scenes for sure
so the big twist here um is dan is now
in 1994.
do you think in dan's mind
he would still go save melody if he knew
this was going to happen
would he do it again
i think
there comes a period there's a there's a
point
early in the script
that dan has found his life purpose
absolutely absolutely there's he would
do everything the same probably with a
little bit more uh sureness
um
i i do think so yeah because that you
know again he's restoring he's he's an
archivist he's restored like you know
what's lost and this is his chance to do
that but for real
um i think this is everything that he's
wanted to do it's scary it's frightening
it's it's life-threatening but it's
everything that i've wanted to do my
entire life i love that so
now looking into the future
if a season two comes about is there
anything you would like to see
dan do or change in himself maybe in the
future of this story uh i just want that
guy to have like a moment of peace
you know
like even just like
just some just something you know
uh because it starts off in a ghost and
he's in it and he's in it he's in it and
those moments of melody i think are
moments of peace
um
but i i just want i just want him to
find some some real happiness some
tangible
constant like i mean i guess you can't
say constant happiness but you know
something that just really feeds him in
in a real way
um that's not so transient
i love that and i i hope i i'm sure
we're gonna get a season two for this
this is gonna be a hit people love this
thing everybody make sure to re-watch
archive 81 tell your friends about it
it's all on netflix watch mama do crush
it as dan mama do thank you so much for
joining me today and i hope to talk to
you in the future oh likewise it was a
pleasure talking to you steve thanks so
much